in the year 2000 and worldwide
I was invited to found the question
next that is the greatest resources
they are used in Latin America very
interesting question I think your people
particularly the young women
and minorities the face of america
latina is a young face on 19.5 of the
population of latin america is today not
only surpassed by Africa by 20 by
percent however 82 percent of
the young people of latin america are
unemployed or underemployed the case of
the least the same unemployment are
god percent above the average and
of the 570 million inhabitants of
latin america there are 218 million
people outside the systems of
integration and social protection that's why
I think the solution is
basically in two areas
the creation of productive employment and
also economic